the South Park Pander verse episode that
everyone's been talking about it's
marketed as the characters are replaced
by diverse women so Cartman is a black
woman now but there's there's an a story
and a b story and the B story is that no
one knows how to do anything and so uh
Randy Marsh Stan's dad the stove breaks
and he's like I'm going to show you kids
how to fix the stove the stove door so
he calls the handyman and then the
handyman's like well I'm going to have
to come back later your you know the the
the screws are stripped and he's like
wait I'll pay you more money to stay and
fix it now and he goes ah someone
already paid me more money to go fix
theirs now so what happens is all the
all the handymen end up becoming
billionaires and then when none of the
regular people can get their light bulbs
fixed or their power outlets fixed or
anything fixed they start blaming the
billionaires because the handy men are
all billionaires and then they start
holding up we are the 99% signs they're
saying capitalism has failed they're
like all these billionaires are
withholding their access to this work
and we can't get anything fixed now it's
their fault capitalism's failed us